[Music]
where are we we are in the pop-up from
the 18c hello lab series starter pack in
which you are the stars the main star
and you're pretty funny in it yeah so
we're gonna go on a little tour right
now I want to see all the different
activations I want to see what you guys
have to offer this is open all weekend
long right
yeah and fans can come out and meet us
and who else from the cast is gonna be
here this weekend Alyson Stoner we have
jasmine love you got cash we got you we
got mean yeah well let's go that's gonna
do this let's check it out here is the
pin wheel of death based on the loading
this is it I would say personified it's
basically a person so here we go check
it out get that dollar just as stressful
as real life and I love it beautiful and
you can make do what you do when you see
the rainbow pinwheel of death on your
computer yeah accurate I love it okay
over here these are two my favorite
emojis do use these a lot that one is
definitely my top one the sad crying
face yeah it's more like a sarcastic
fact okay so you put it when you're
actually happy when you're actually
excited when do you use it oh I use that
I use that a lot yeah that's what my
frequent frequently used emojis what is
your most frequently used emoji
let me see let's see we're gonna change
thank you call this the pit of tears
this represents all the memes I've ever
made that don't have over 600k likes
what is your average like on a photo on
my personal home yes and we can never
say with the algorithm I'd say it's
anywhere between thirty thousand and two
hundred thousand there's it's I don't
even get it I don't know two hundred
thousand lakes no big deal you guys
how I get my validation in life how was
that actually pretty liberating yeah I
had to put a lot of trust in the balls
and the balls trusted me hey doin asking
about starter packs what drew you to
this project what drew meets the starter
pack besides just so much fun and it was
about means which are very relevant what
drew me a Bryce is that he's kind of a
jerk I find it easy to play a jerk
because people in my past have called me
a jerk and it's pretty easy for me to
play a jerk I don't think you're a jerk
come on I'm nice to you cuz I'm on
camera
ah but when the camera goes off you mean
I turn into a jerk like wow look at the
meanwhile which one do you feel like you
relate to most I relate to this one on
the bottom left the most switching
between the same five apps which apps
Instagram Twitter YouTube my texts and
selfie camera cuz I have to constantly
make sure that I look good at any moment
in case in case someone invites me out
for the night this looks like Ian it
kind of does from the Smosh that does
look like him kind of looks like his
face with my old hairstyle yeah video
games over here we got the gaming pods
over here we got the standard Windows XP
wallpaper here just to make you feel
like you're really going into a portal
here into another dimension you come
here you could play as me I don't know
what okay I want to see how close their
hairstyle is to mine because last time I
looked they just have wait is it
characters from the series yeah
confirmed right now live from ET we got
did the characters from starter pack be
made right now are you making me yeah
make sure they has extra curly please I
want to see the closest to my hair look
at that we're gonna continue on this
tour this is the photo wall
where I'll be doing a meet-up oh this is
where it happened this is where the
magic happens yeah and I'll be flexing
my fame here taking photos of people
hair tutorials is that happening if
someone asks nicely and there's a cat
wall which is I think my favorite part
there's a cow ball here yeah called the
internet catty who is your favorite
internet cat my favorite Internet
and not be named today for your legal
copyright it was the grouchy cat listen
to my abilities Beethoven I did just
play Beethoven spit but it took a long
time to learn how to play keyboard
upside down but all the hard work has
paid off yeah this moment why should
people come out to this pop up come out
I think you have a lot of fun especially
if you like the series maybe a lot of
the cast here we are just so excited to
meet the people that I've been watching
there's just so many fun things there's
a ball pit I'm hopefully the ball pick
up anything I'll be here this weekend
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]